um
okay so next episode though we got a
little uh a little uh preview of next
episode and faye is very mad at jake
because
she's like no jake you're faking it yeah
jake the fake yeah
she's the most genuine person and you
demo and you're pissing me off yeah and
you voted for us you had the goal to
vote for us
yeah for us
you're pissing me off they're pissing me
off it was so great underneath it
punches it on face or on teddy's face
he's like
that's the greatest all you can do there
cause jake it punches on and on him and
he just goes
jesus
i thought there's gonna be more drama
and like what he's gonna say he just
gets he just rolls over jesus was the
pasta that bad yeah jesus
imagine he just said something so mean
to her before they cut that part out
all right jake go over there and tell
faye
she's a gun she's a yeah
in an american accent yeah say [ __ ] like
an american
and then tell her you don't like fake
women
oh they give him a pun yeah they're like
it's interesting
hugo
you know something about hugo and like
you're the fakest one here just make it
up we don't [ __ ] tell her tell her uh
you can't spell fake without fay
tell her that
fake i put you for a chat
yeah sure
no she would go
yeah fine yeah
so i've been i've been thinking a lot
with lib
and i think
you can't spell fake without faith
just the producers are like
good job buddy good job
good job exactly what we need here yeah
you saved the show
got 10 days later you're our good boy
you're a winner you're a good boy aren't
you jake oh my god they have like some
stick relationships
listen
jake
you may not win this whole thing you
want some scratches right here come here
but we're gonna make you
a star
you're gonna be our little influencer
he's scratching his beard you like to
influence jake he's like me
yeah yeah i like influence i like greece
jake i like greece do you i love it yeah
what do you like about greece it's blue
blue eyes
you like to go there you like you like
skinny bunny tea jake
dude
this just sounds like a [ __ ] chapter
out of the odyssey or something
you just develop some sick relationship
with the ocean
that's what he sees in liberty's eyes
liberty's eyes
grace
influencer
what have you done to him he's a lot
weirder than the beginning of the
season
you like greece liberty
[Laughter]
i like meekness i love making it
look into his eyes
oh my god it's blue like
greece yeah and then
then jake goes out there and he's good
boy jake
you're a good boy
oh my god
he goes back to the producer's room
every time he did good
i did good
i did good for the producer they put
them in a high chair yeah
jake did good job
[Laughter]
jake did real good job
now jake it's time for your favorite
snack date love snacks
little mac and cheese for you yeah
is before i put it in your mouth
what are you
it takes a good point jake no no
take jake's a snake
[Laughter]
i'm a little snake say it again
i'm a little snake
can't spell jake without snake
exactly
exactly
are you are you willing to rat on
everyone else in here
yup yup eat rats spit them out
love rap
who do you love
you guys
know who else on the show liberty yep
you sure do love liberty's eyes
he's like a clone yeah he's got this
mush for brains and they're just
programming
first day on set they sit him then like
all right jake look to the camera he's
like all right and then just lobotomize
him
[Music]
install a chip in the back of his head
reboot his ass
all right jake
who's your favorite
liberty what do you like about her her
eyes why they're blue
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
reboot him
reboot him
bring him back
what why that's why when they saw that
clipper he's like yeah you know i'm just
physically it's not all there for me
that was moments before they got him
yeah and then
yeah i love you
[Laughter]
i love you
it's just nuts man
i just feel like the words are just
coming out like they're not coming from
me it's like it's like it's liberating
i love you
it's like i don't want to say them but i
love i love you i liberty i love you
so much they're just rewriting his
thoughts at one time
libra i don't know how to say
i love you
help me i love you
they're in my head
they're in my head the thoughts about
you they're in my head
i love you it said
kill me
[Laughter]
i don't want to kiss i don't want to
kiss
yeah i'm a girlfriend i'm a girlfriend
you're my girlfriend you're my
girlfriend
jake's gone really weird
[Laughter]
do they think
who thinks i'm not being genuine i'm not
i'm
i am being genuine i'm not being genuine
that's what he tried to run out he was
trying to escape but they [ __ ] made
his homing device come back it was like
an elizabeth it's like an invisible
fence like you get shocked
i've go get out of here
jake
[Laughter]
that wouldn't be very nice jake
don't you want your macaroni
i love macaroni
turn his body around
[Laughter]
jesus [ __ ] dude
we need to write just a whole show
that's this
it says
someone on my
i don't want to do this anymore
well you could close it out with some
scottish slang yeah scottish accent
scottish not really yeah
this is probably going to be irish you
bet this
yeah better settle down
all right old fella the old fella was
old fella i mean that was pretty obvious
that old fellow was running around like
a bat out of hell like like a
like you know it's like a
like a scoundrel right
yeah a little pest yeah that little pest
was it an old man oh it's literally just
an old man oh horny little deviant oh
we're guessing
yeah it's trivia
all right copy that all right next
the young boy is a real skinny malinky
long legs
paul this probably means like attractive
you think so no it's definitely
tall yeah like a tall like a tyler type
yeah
yeah tall tall and skinny person yep
nailed the thought
oh that would be a sick word for
smashing these habits of yours are pure
bogging
yeah we bogged
oh yeah we both disgusting disgusting
burger is bogging dude
this [ __ ] is bogging off right now no
you know it was a as some slaying i
caught i it was like real indiscreet or
not not really in your face it was tyler
he was saying i was gobbed like
gobsmacked
because i was gulped maggie i was golfed
i was like that's it's kind of kind of
like that yeah that's pretty cool
clipe don't be a weak clipper don't be a
weak life don't be a weak clippy
tattle oh
oh a rat
six nine wee little clippy
we clap
oh you're sure a week live that's irish
on her off days she's a bit crabbit uh
crabby
yeah like
that's the last that's the latin um
uh third person tense of krabby yeah
just that's fae
yeah grumpy yeah
dufty oh we know that one dumbass debbie
doff that dufty couldn't tell skye from
sea that dumb ass
knew it munter munter i've heard this
before even on his best days charles is
still pure munto material we used to say
munted in australia for like really
[ __ ] up we'd be like we got munted
last night so this is like an idiot i
would assume dumbass yeah maybe munter
ugly oh damn well maybe the girls were
just saying that i was munted yeah
yeah
yeah dude i was really drunk last night
yeah you're really monday no you was
mounted are you really minted
yo munter is [ __ ] mean that has to
come from some horrible
historical
period where that word is like true
super negative connotation
skunnered
we went for a kiss and got rejected i
was pure skunner uh getting curved
shocked
i'm not mad i'm just scannered
oh that's it the end all right we did
pretty good we got like 10 out of 10.
yeah scottish people let us know how we
did
look
guys we're coming to the end i know you
want to see us play the game we will be
doing a couple bonus episodes playing
the game
just exclusively
and uh and next week
you know is the date now it's the
[ __ ] date week everybody
so next episode is going to be a tough
one
we have to really
just reach down in some weird places
when they talk and date i don't [ __ ]
care i don't care at all
and their their conversations are not
good yeah
but we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll
see we'll we'll we'll plant some fun
stuff for next week yeah [ __ ] we'll
keep it fun no worries [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you